- To me the Klan is
basically a family tradition.
If you think about it, I mean,
at one time in America,
there was so many members during the 1920s
one out of three Americans
were members of the KKK.
- [Interviewer] Yeah, I was
talking to my dad this morning
- [Chris] But it was a popular thing.
- [Interviewer] He was
saying it was a big deal
when he was a kid, in Indiana.
- [Chris] Oh
- [Interviewer] He went to Purdue.
- [Chris] Yeah he was in
D.C. Stephenson state.
It was the hugest state ever was Indiana,
D.C. Stephenson.
He ran it then.
Yeah, I can imagine.
I might make me a cloth through this satin
- [Member] Too much material.
- [Chris] I know.
I'm saying, I need to get
something like that cloth
The screw looks (mumbles)
Is that hot?
- [Member] It's warm.
- This one's real hot
- [Member] It'll be good in winter though.
- I remember when I was
younger and I got my first robe
but I got one in cotton
and all the officers
told me not to ever get one in satin,
It'll be hotter than hell.
Then being an Imperial Wizard,
you got to have one in Satin.
- [Interviewer] So what
is the difference between
a Grand Dragon and an Imperial Wizard?
- Imperial Wizard's over the
whole Klan, the whole group.
And the Grand Dragon is over the State.
Like he's the Grand
Dragon of North Carolina.
The man over there is the
Grand Dragon from Florida.
So each clan has Grand
Dragons over the State.
And then under them, they
have 'Exalted Cyclops'
which is presidents of
each individual unit.
- [Interviewer] And you've
been in the clan for how long?
- About 23, 24 years. I joined in 1997.
I know that (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] How'd
you join, what happened?
- Well, I was at a Walmart one day
and a guy walked up handed me a flyer,
telling me that there was a
Klan rally right up the road
and wanting to know if I would attend it.
I had a Confederate flag shirt on
and I guess that's the reason
why he gave me the flyer.
So I wound up attending the rally.
And to me, at first I was skeptic
because you hear all the bad stuff
about the Klan killing
people and all that.
So, I got a flyer while I was there
for the next rally
telling me when to come.
It was basically the invitation to show
to people at the gate on how to get in
because without the
paper I couldn't get in
because I wasn't a member.
So the second rally was, I think it was
within a month after I
went back again, just to
hang out mingle with the
people, see what they're about.
And when I got done listening
to a lot of the speeches
I felt, you know, they
believed the same way I do.
So that's what made me join.
I mean, they're against drugs,
We're against abortion,
homosexuality, race mixing,
and everything in the Bible
is basically the same thing
the Klan clan was talking about.
The clan was telling me, you
know, race mixing is wrong,
Homosexuality is wrong, but
all this is in the Bible
and that's one thing I
liked about the Klan is
they were showing me where
to find it at in the Bible.
And you know, I've been
to a lot of churches
and most of the churches
are 501(c)(3) churches
they're owned by the government,
ran by the government.
They're told what to preach.
So a lot of the verses
they were showing me in the
King James version of the Bible,
was verses I've never seen or heard.
So it shocked me and I
found it very knowledgeable,
So I kept going to the rallies
and I kept reading the Bible
and then wound up becoming
a member of the KU Klux Klan
in 1997.
And I think by the summer,
yeah by the time summer was over
I was a full-blown member of the KKK.
And I don't regret a bit of it.
I mean, I've loved the clan
and I'll always love the clan
and do whatever I can to help it grow.
- [Interviewer] What's the basic belief
behind the Ku Klux Klan?
- Basic belief behind the KU
Klux Klan is that, you know
as a race as a whole, we
need to stick together.
All the other races are sticking together.
You have, you know, groups
for the African-Americans,
you got Black Panthers, Black
Lives Matter, you got NAACP.
But if you look, there is
no white groups out there
to support white people.
That will actually stick up
and stand for white people
and help them out when in need,
you know, the nigger, the Mexicans,
they can all run to the
government and get loans
and get welfare, while
a white man can't do it.
It's impossible basically
for whites to go out
and get these services.
So the clan to me, it's
always stood there to help
white people who are in need
and I'll always support it.
And I think the Klan
is a great organization
and it's been here 150 years
in support of the white race.
And right now in America,
the way things are going
it's a double standard on the media.
Every time you turn around,
the blacks are rioting.
I think it's time for
the clan to rise back up
and do it all again.
We need to actually get up
and fight for the white race
or there ain't gonna be no white race.
- [Interviewer] What's the
biggest issue for the clan today?
Is it immigration or race
mixing or separatism?
- Its a little bit of both.
I mean, we've got more
immigrants right now.
Immigration is costing the
United States American taxpayers,
$320,000,000,000 a year.
And that's illegal immigration.
I mean, that money could
be spent on other things
like helping our veterans,
helping the homeless,
whether they black or white,
the clan is not a hate group.
I could tell people we're not about hate.
We just want to live
separate from the other races
just like the Bible intended.
You know, that's one of the
things that preacher showed me
a long time ago, it was at a Klan rally.
And I recognize a lot of the Klan.
A lot of Klan rallies had
a lot of preachers there
and you know, and he
showed me the Bible verse;
Leviticus 19:18
Cause you always hear people
holler 'love thy neighbor'
But then when you read the
verse for yourself, it says;
'love thy neighbor of thy people'
And my people are white people.
So that's exactly what I'm
doing, is carrying out.
You know, God's wishes.
I want to love my people
and help my people
just as every other race
has the right to help
and benefit their race.
I mean, that's it.
They should have the right to do that.
And I feel right now in America
we're losing our right as white
people, as the white race,
to defend ourselves or to even speak out.
You know, if you say
you're proud to be white
they pretty much label you are racist.
And to me that's just a,
racist is just a made up word.
I mean, it was made up by a
communist Jew named Leon Trotsky
in 1936, was the first
time that it was used
during a debate.
And he was using it to cut people down.
And if that's the way
they're going to use it,
then I guess I would
be considered a racist
and I'm proud to be a racist.
- [Interviewer] And the Klan
is a Christian organization?
- Yes, Christian organization.
We read same Bible, everybody else does.
We just actually read all
the Bible instead of skip
through like these a Judea
Christian preachers do today.
- [Interviewer] What are
the aspects of Christianity
that the Klan is based on?
- Well, it's based on the whole, ritual,
the Klan ritual, like
when you get naturalized
or which naturalization
ceremony is a Klan ceremony.
We use the Bible to swear
you in and to become
a full fledged member of the Klan.
So, I mean, we want to
stick by the laws of God
and you know, you ain't
going to make it to the
kingdom of heaven unless you
stick by the laws of god.
So that's one thing we try
to teach in our family.
You know, this was
taught 30, 40 years ago.
I remember, you know, you
wouldn't see colored people,
mixing and going into
a church 30 years ago,
not in this state.
And now the preachers are allowing it.
And that's to me is
sickening, and It's sickening
to see these preachers sell
out their congregations
and damn their own
congregation straight to hell,
by pushing all this equality nonsense,
knowing hat the Bible says all
the races should be separate.
And that when Christ comes back,
he says he shall separate all races again,
separate all people by their tongues
and put them in their own nations.
That's in Matthew 15.
So I mean, to me, the Bible
and the Klan go hand in hand.
- [Interviewer] Chris, I'm
going to ask if you can maybe
take off your sunglasses
when you answer it.
- No I won't take off my glasses.
- [Interviewer] You wanna keep them on?
- Yeah. For right now (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Okay.
Are you open to take them off at all?
- No.
- [Interviewer] Okay.
- I used to,
but this thing got so bad
where now they see me on TV
wherever I work at,
they usually terminate me (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] Okay understood.
- I've done lost two jobs
now for being in the KKK.
- [Interviewer] Is that right?
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] What
does it take to become
an Imperial wizard?
- You have to be in the
clan for years, like I said,
I joined it when I was 17, just turned 18.
And you got to Know all
four of your degrees,
which is what these are for.
Like, this is a Knight's committee,
your first degree is Cannery,
your second degree is
Knight's committee, is your second degree.
Third degree is Knights
of the Great Force,
And then your fourth and final degree is;
Knights of the Midnight Mystery.
- [Interviewer] And you guys
have problems, you know,
you want to stay separate from
African-Americans, Mexicans,
- Jews, Arabs, Chinese, it don't matter.
I would love to see a white
Homeland established one day.
- [Interviewer] And a
gay community as well?
- The what?
- [Interviewer] The gay community as well?
- They are an abomination,
gay people supposed to be
put to death upon sight.
And that's in Romans 11.
It's also in Leviticus 20:13,
homosexuals are supposed to
be put to death upon sight.
- [Interviewer] Are there
still lynchings anywhere?
- No. The clan ain't never lynch people.
That's another myth that
I helped destroy years ago
when I was doing an interview for Fox.
As I told them; "show
me a picture of the Klan
lynching somebody"
and they're ropes, and a black
person hanging into this day.
Nobody has been able
to produce the picture
cause it never happened.
And like I told people, look it up.
Lynchings were common by what they call
'Lynch mobs' back then.
And if you look at the
photos of anywhere where
a black person hanging,
you don't see KKK people
you see the towns people because it was a
common event back then, when
somebody committed a crime
they hung them and the whole
town would come out there
and have popcorn for sale.
It's basically like one
big carnival, but yet
it got pushed on the clan a lot,
that the clan went out
and lynched these people.
Look in any picture of any
lynching and you'll see
it ain't the KKK, it's the
town's people themselves.
- [Interviewer] The community
you're living in here,
in North Carolina.
There's quite a few people
of African-American descent.
- Yeah.
- [Interviewer] And is there friction
between the races here?
- [Chris] Well, one thing I
like about where we live at is
we all pretty much stay separate.
I mean, America can push the
myth that we're all equal
and we're all living in
a multicultural society.
But in reality, America's more
segregated now than it was
30 years ago.
Or 50 years ago.
I mean, every time you walked
into a church on Sunday,
It's segregated.
When you go to the prisons,
the races segregates
There aint not racial tension
in this side of North Carolina
now you go towards Charlotte and Raleigh,
It's probably a lot of racial tension
but up here it's a peaceful community.
- [Interviewer] Everyone
stays to themselves?
- [Chris] Yeah, everyone pretty
much stays to themselves.
- [Interviewer] How has the
clan changed over the years?
- [Chris] To me, the clan has
become more modernized to me.
It ain't like it was
when I joined, you know,
it was more secretive
back when I was younger.
And some Klan groups still
want to keep themselves
in the shadows and do things,
while we and the lord of the
White Knights of the KKK,
were more open.
We'll go out Marching the streets,
We'll March through
towns and do courthouse,
public demonstrations.
While back, you know,
years ago, a lot of Klans
wouldn't even think about
doing stuff like that.
They didn't want people
knowing who they were.
They was worried about their identities.
Like I said, I've lost two jobs from it
but I still haven't quit doing it
and I'll continue doing
it until the day I die.
And so I think the clans
more nowadays is actually
coming more out into the open.
- And 10 years ago, it
was kind of harder to get
people to join.
But now with all the
racial tension in America
people are joining and lift and right
so I think it's a good thing.
When these people were rioting
and causing all these riots
for a black guy named George Floyd,
who was a career criminal.
The man was just let out of
prison for armed robbery.
He broke into a woman's
house, a pregnant woman
and put a gun to her stomach
and made her give over all
her cash and credit cards.
He pulled five years
in prison and gets out
goes in the store, trying to
pass counterfeit money off,
counterfeit bills, trying to
buy more alcohol and cigarettes
and gets killed by the police.
I feel no sympathy for
him. The man's a criminal.
And I think these riots are
helping the Klan greatly.
There's more people
out looking for us now.
It used to be, we had to
go out and recruit members.
Now we just sit back and they come to us.
- [Interviewer] And
what do you think about
the state of our country?
Do you think things are getting worse?
- I think it's a racial
powder keg about the explode
and we're actually hoping for it.
Most of the people in
the Klan want it too.
We want the racial tension...
We want a race war. Full out race war.
- [Interviewer] And racism is a big issue
in the United States -
- Oh, racism is always going
to be a big issue anywhere
you can't have two different
races or three races.
You can't have this many
people living on one continent
with this many different religions,
this many different cultures,
without one trying to step on the other.
I mean, that's just common sense.
- [Interviewer] But you could argue
that the Klan is contributing
to the problem, no?
- No, the clan ain't
contributing to the problem,
you can just sit back, let
the blacks do their own job.
I mean, let them keep killing
each other in record numbers.
The clan ain't got to go
out and kill blacks no more.
We just drop off some liquor
in their town and some guns
and they do it themselves (chuckles)
If it was my option, every
weekend I would go up to Chicago
with a big truck full of
whiskey and crack, marijuana
and a ton of guns and bullets
and tell them 'have at it'
and just drop it off right
in the middle of town
and then go home and watch
them on Monday morning news
and laugh the whole time (chuckles)
- [Interviewer] What's
the most important thing
you've learned in your life?
- To never turn my back on God.
He'll always be there for me.
And like I said, the Klans
is a religious movement,
when I was younger, I
really wasn't into religion
but I see there's a whole
new generation coming up
that are basically Atheist
and I feel sorry for them
so I try to reach out to
people about the Bible
and the goodness of the Bible.
And you know, God's there for everybody.
Who's there willing to listen.
- [Interviewer] What are you
proudest of in your life?
- My kids.
- [Interviewer] You have two boys?
- Yeah two boys.
- [Interviewer] And are they
involved in the Klan at all?
- (Clears throat) They've
been involved in the Klan,
they were basically born into the Klan.
They've been going to rallies
since they could crawl,
you know, on the rally field.
So yeah, they feel the
same way we do, you know,
they are seeing it, you know.
I didn't raise them to be racially aware.
That's the thing is, we
took them to riots when
they were little, as they got
older they wanted to hang out
with the little black kids down the road,
the little Mexican kids.
So my wife was against it
and I told her, I said,
that's the best thing for them.
Let them go out there and
meet these other cultures
and these other races so that,
you know, they used to hang
out with the black kids down
the road and the Mexican kids.
I thought it was funny.
I think it lasted about eight months.
And then my kids come
home one day and said,
I ain't hanging out with them no more.
And them I'm like why?
And they're like, 'well
every time I turned around
and my stuff's getting stolen
out my room and I'm finding
you know, the little black
boys room down there'
So they pretty much put
it together themselves
that these people, you
know, they're not civilized.
African-Americans, Mexicans,
these people are not civilized.
Asians, they're not civilized.
You've got Asian gangs tearing
up California every weekend.
- [Interviewer] Have you
traveled to other countries?
- I've traveled all
over the United States.
The Klans are an American base group.
And it should always have
American citizens as its members,
We shouldn't have Germans. You
know, they got a Nazi party.
If they want something
similar to the Klan,
let them stick with the Nazi party.
- [Interviewer] Who are you going to be
voting for this fall?
- So far we're still gonna vote for Trump,
even though he's pretty
much selling us out.
Every time I turn on
television he's giving
more and more money to the Jews in Israel.
And to me, we have given
enough to that country.
We give 38 billion a year,
in foreign aid to Israel
and I don't get why we keep
giving to these people.
I don't care for the Holocaust lie.
I wish they'd go and tell the
truth about the Holocaust,
that you know, it was
our soldiers who've done
the killing of the Jews.
And I think they should tell
the truth, that we bought
the concentration camps,
thinking that they were
military bases of the Germans.
And we're basically, it would
be the American government,
the British government
and Canadian government
are responsible for the
Holocaust, it wasn't the Germans.
But to me, to use that $38
billion could help the veterans,
could help homeless.
I mean, right now our economy
is in a lot of trouble.
We could use that 38 billion.
I think we should cut all
foreign aid to Israel.
Or Israel hell as a lot of people like to
call it around here,
because that's all it is.
It's a nation that was stolen
from the Palestinian people
and they have no birthright to it.
If anybody has a birthright, Israel
it'd be the chosen
people of the white race.
Just as the Bible says.
- [Interviewer] Was your family
racist when you were a kid?
- Nope.
No, my parents actually hated the fact
that I joined the Klan (chuckles)
When they found out
they were actually upset
and told me to get out of that type stuff.
And you know, it took them about I think,
about six, seven years
ago my momma called me
and she said, "you know
what? I've changed my mind"
She said, "I'm kind of proud
of what you've been doing"
You know, marching in the
streets for the white race,
And she said, "I'm kind of proud."
She said everything that,
you know over the years
of talking to them, they finally started
looking into what I was saying.
And they found out it's all true.
You know, the Jews control
the media and the bank
and they're using it as
basically as a weapon
against the white race.
That's why our money has federal
reserve note on top of it.
It's no better than toilet paper.
I mean, it ain't even a real currency.
That's why other nations are turning away
from the US dollar.
And I think that's going
to be the eventually,
collapse of our country
is the way Russia, China
and all of them are turning
away from the US dollar,
our dollars basically worthless.
And like I said, I hope one
day our economy does fall
and people could actually
see who's behind the banks,
who's behind the media.
And who's trying to tell us it's okay
even though we're living
in a concrete jungle
that's what America is; a concrete jungle.
There's blacks killing
whites in record numbers.
That's the FBI statistics
say they kill close
to half a million whites every year,
while whites kill blacks at 30,
I think it was three
30,586 blacks got killed
by whites last year.
- [Chris] But they killed
half a million of our people.
So I think, you know, why
isn't this info on the news?
Why do I have to go to the
government websites to get it?
That's because the Jews
are covering it all up.
And our TVs becoming more degenerative.
Every time I watched the
television, I get sick
because I'm starting to see
more homosexuality on TV
more race mixing propaganda,
pushed down my throat.
So I turned off my cable.
I don't have satellite or nothing.
If I want to watch television,
I go through the internet
and download the movies I want to watch.
So I watched a lot of the
older television shows like;
Andy Griffin, the Monsters,
Beverly Hillbillies,
I'd rather watch stuff
like that than the filth
they're trying to feed me today.
- [Interviewer] All right Chris,
well thank you so much
for talking with me.
- [Chris] Let somebody else?